what we haven't talked about its
collaboration yeah Eddie sort of
creativity whatever you are even if
you're a fine artist it isn't that
collaboration and you are quite specific
about what you bring to the party the
visual the imaginative but you always
work with great writers well I have to
because I'm not a very good writer i
mean i can write situation i can write
the ideas I i can have ideas about the
characters but i don't write good
dialogue it's very simple and so I
always work with people who can and I
love working and I think that comes from
you know once you're in a group like
pison and even though I was separate to
some degree it was always collaborative
and I love working with other people and
it's one reason I got bored with
animation because it just me in the
paper and I'll of other people's ideas i
love the need that I have to argue for
why I want something I've got to
convince somebody else which is very
important round just saying I want it
it's the whole process and I love also
that's when the actors really become
wonderful cuz you've spent a year or so
writing it repairing it getting all
everything ready you go to work and now
the actors come in and I spent a lot of
time choosing hopefully the right people
and then they come in with very
different ideas about how to do a C and
so that the daily business of shooting
becomes surprising all the time it's
interesting it'll be on your toes it's
not it's not me just following my story
board's decision process yeah and it's
anything the process it's it's very
organic consents and the nature comes in
and rains when it's supposed to be a
sunny day so everything is a shifting it
so the whole process is alive it doesn't
mean it's fun it most the time I'm
screaming and tearing my hair out
because it's not the way I want it but
that's but the point is this in to
surround yourself with people who are
really good who are opinionated who
don't want yes ma'am I watched so many
filmmakers and see they're surrounded by
yes big event and no I want people that
argue with me and say what are you doing
then I remember the first time we were
doing time Bennett's I got myself in a
corner literally shooting into a corner
and a whole set is back there and I
couldn't quite make it work and the prop
guy came by the prop guy and he said
what are you doing Terry and he prop guy
talking to direct like that wait a
minute there's a hierarchy he right here
a hierarchy here now but he said why
don't we just do that Mike and basically
is it kidnapping and I I just didn't
stop he's absolutely right and so ever
since then I just listened to everybody
and I'm not um neurotic or insecure to
reject all these ideas because
ultimately I'm smart enough to know that
I have the ultimate power of deciding
yay or nay and I keep saying the people
because people think I'm an auteur I'm
not I'm a field too yeah it's what I am
that's all I always come from everybody
and I get the credit or blame that's my
job